Hallo liebe Podcast-Fans, für die heutige Folge haben unsere beiden Comedy-Helden Florentin und Stefan etwas ganz Besonderes vorbereitet. Sie nehmen die Folge nämlich aus einer verlassenen Druckerei für lustige Autohaufkleber auf. Und nun viel Spaß mit der Folge. Ja, dazu ganz kurz. Ihr werdet es wahrscheinlich relativ bald merken, aber ich bin krank. Die Krankheit hat mich in ihrem eiskalten Griff erfasst und vielen, vielen Dank an Jan, der sich so ein lustiges Opening überlegt hat für unsere Folge, aber mir ist heute wirklich nicht nach Lachen zumute. Hallo Stefan. Ja, hallo Florentin, ja auch da draußen geht eine Entschuldigung raus an alle, die hier eine normale Podcast-UFO-Folge hören wollen, sorry, eine normale Das-Podcast-UFO-Folge hören wollen. Da geht es schon los. Ja, es ist ein bisschen problematisch, vorhin ist es ganz doll krank. Wir machen den Krankenflügel, die grosse Krankenflügel Woche. Wir reden ein bisschen leiser. Wir reden vor allem nicht so viel über lustige Sachen, sondern auch mal heute geht es mal um Gesundheit. Sichtum, Verderbnis, inneres Verfaulen. Danke Stefan, dass du mich besucht hast. Du bist vorbeigekommen mit einer Packung Pralinen. Von denen hast du jetzt die meisten gegessen. Ich stand halt so ein bisschen im Stau, habe einen Packplatz nicht gefunden und dann habe ich halt so nebenbei so aus Frust die Pralinen mir reingepfeffert. Es war ein Messie an mich, dass ich überhaupt hierher gekommen bin. Ach so, und die lagen vorne auf der Kühlerhaube, weil die waren sehr geschmolzen. Aber am Aturenbrett glaube ich. Ich hatte gerne kochend heiß im Auto, so 38 Grad. Und dann, ja, also den Tee, wie gesagt, du hast mir gesagt, kannst du mir Tee mitbringen, ich habe den mitgebracht. Er ist nur auf dem Weg, leider einfach, ja, es ist alles, das ganze Auto ist voller Teebeutel. Diesen Fenchelgeruch kriegst du auch nicht mehr raus. Nein, nein. Es gibt auch manche Sachen, die sind einfach unwiederbringlich mit Krankheit verbunden. Also ich trinke natürlich jetzt viel Tee und der Körper sagt, ach wir sind krank? Ach so, ja gut, dann mache ich alle Läden zu. So dann, all Starbucks ist zu, komplett die Mall ist geschlossen, alles zu, weil der Körper auch checkt, ah Pfefferminz, oh da muss es ja, kein Spaß. Nee. Ich bin wirklich krank. Wir powern hier durch, denn ihr seid uns natürlich wichtig. Du, du powerst hier durch. Du bist locker, ich hoffe ... Kerngesund zum ersten Mal. Ja, man kann natürlich auch jetzt wahrscheinlich in Echtzeit beobachten, wie ich dich anstecke in dieser Folge, wie ich dich runterziehe in meinen Moloch und komplett unten am Boden meines selbst geschaufelten Grabes liege. Ja, es war ein Fehler, diese Aufnahme zu starten.
Das merke ich jetzt, jetzt ist es zu spät, jetzt sind wir drin,
jetzt rotschen wir diesen Hang herunter, die Lawine hinter uns wird größer und größer.
Kurzen Einblick hinter die Kulissen, Florentin kam an und hat gesagt,
ich glaube, es war ein Fehler.
Und ich glaube, mit diesem ersten Satz noch vom Hallo ist alles gesagt.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben ja generell immer zu viel Energie in den Folgen.
Leute sagen, schreit nicht so rum, macht die Folgen mal leiser, die sind zu laut.
Mittlerweile sind sie zu laut, es ist das große Pendeln.
So und jetzt war so ein bisschen zu viel Inhalt.
Auch die Waveform hat teilweise gesagt, Leute, hallo, ich kann auch Details anzeigen, ich bin nicht ein Balken, ich bin nicht ein fucking Rechteck. Und dann, genau, jetzt können wir mal sagen, ey, jetzt lernt ihr uns auch mal von der Seite kennen, wo wir sagen, ey, wir machen mal ein bisschen weniger Energie. So sind wir vielleicht normal im echten Leben, eher als in den Folgen, wo wir immer so super energetisch weißt, wir machen immer gute Miene zum bösen Spiel Spiel. Das stimmt. Uns geht schon lange sehr, sehr schlecht. Und heute kommt alles raus. Und es ist einfach nicht mehr gut gelaufen in der letzten Zeit. Ich bin krank, ich husse. Wo ich den Schal her habe, den gibt es im Podcast-Ufo-Merchstore. Den könnt ihr euch dort besorgen. Ich habe auch dankenswerterweise einen zugeschickt bekommen. Und den konnten ihn gut tragen. Und vielleicht wird das auch ein dauerhaftes Accessoire. Ich glaube, bei Schalträgern war das wahrscheinlich meistens so, man war krank, man trägt den Schal als, ja, wahrscheinlich absolut wirkungsloses Arzneimittel. Also die letzte Bataillon, so das, was man so auf, umlegt, um nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen wo er was eigentlich, den Hals warm zu halten? Das Immunsystem, das gerade eine verlorene Schlacht um Helms Klamm kämpft und plötzlich sie schauen nach Osten und dann kommt so eine Trage. Dann kommen so zwei Sannis mit so einer Trage an. Also, okay, was sollen wir damit machen? Dafür habt ihr ein Horn gestossen? Wir dachten, ein Horn ist so ab 100 oder so. Warum habt ihr überhaupt ein Horn alleine? Wir haben halt diese Trage.
Naja, gut, aber okay, bei Horn denkt man ...
Wir haben eine Trage und ein Horn.
Ja, okay, aber da denkt man jetzt, okay, die große Abhilfe ist da und so.
Und ich meine ...
Womit wir gar nicht umgehen, ist diese Energie, die uns gerade entgegenkommt.
Ja, okay, weil ich finde es einfach ...
Wir kommen ... Diese Trage war superschwer, okay?
Die ist aus fucking Eibenholz und so einem schweren Metall. Wir tragen ... Ja, psch,. Wir tragen ... Ich habe ein Uruk-Schwert in meiner Seite. Ich sehe es ja. Ich hätte dir auch schon dann geholfen. Aber da kam es mit dieser uncoolen Negativity hier rein. Und dieses Horn. Weißt du, wie schwer das Horn ist? Ja. Ich habe es getragen. Es war ein guter Stoss ins Horn. Da ist ja überhaupt keine Kritik, nur die Bedeutung. Oh mein Gott, von Westen. Ein Schal. Ja, aber so ist, glaube ich, der Schal zu verstehen. Der Körper sagt Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, ich sterbe, sterbe, sterbe und dann kommt der Mensch mit dem Schal. Ich hätte ja gerne, dass der Körper ein bisschen mehr kommuniziert und ich kenne das zum Beispiel so vom Computer, wenn es irgendwas nicht geht, der Drucker geht nicht und du lädst dir Treiber runter und recherchierst und machst WLAN an, WLAN aus, irgendwas. Und ich hätte gerne so eine Fehlermeldung, pass auf, ich sehe, was du hier versuchst, das wird nicht klappen. Sparen wir uns einfach diesen ganzen Larifari, ich sehe das Problem, das klappt nicht.
Und genauso finde ich, muss es beim Körper auch sein, wo du plötzlich anfängst, irgendwie Hustensaft zu trinken, den du vor zwei Jahren am New Yorker Flughafen gekauft hast. Mir gefällt die Geste, diese kleinen, ja, du fängst an, Hustensaft zu trinken.
In winzigen Dosen, in winzigen Dosen.
In den winzigsten Dosen.
Und dass der Körper einfach so sagt, ey, lass zweimal den linken Ringfinger vibrieren und ich weiss so, all is lost, so, das wird
nichts, du bist jetzt einfach drei Tage
außer Gefecht und dann kriegen wir das schon hin,
so, gib dir keine Mühe, das hätte uns
glaube ich sehr, sehr viel erspart, auch in alten Zeiten,
wo man ja noch weniger Ahnung hatte, wo man
gedacht hat, ja, das ist schon wahrscheinlich die
Geister, ne, also
ist jetzt meine Theorie, dass die,
also dass die Geister und
wahrscheinlich weil, und zu viel Blut, Geister und zu viel Blut. Hat zu viel Blut, das ist eh nicht ideal. Aber wir haben ja bei der Beerdigung haben wir ja dreimal nur mit der Trommel. Und ich habe damals schon gesagt, Leute, drei ist viel zu wenig. Einmal pro Lebensjahr, okay? Also das wäre mindestens drin gewesen. Und jetzt, glaube ich, sehen wir leider die Früchte unseres. Es lag daran, da hat uns Wotan verflucht. Naja, jetzt hat er Geist im Hals. Ich muss aber auch sagen, der Körper warnt nicht früh genug. Und ich, also Moment, Moment, Moment, Gedanken sortieren. Der Körper sagt schon an irgendeinem Punkt mal, hallo, ich werde krank. Das gibt es nämlich dieses Kratzen im Hals. Dieser kleine, erste, dieser komische Geschmack, dieses Abschlucken, es wird ein bisschen so schleimig, da gibt es so einen Weckruf, so ein Hilfesignal. Meines Erachtens. Das erste Leuchtfeuer brennt. Das Leuchtfeuer von? Gondor? Nee, aber das ist doch ein, die heisst das auch anders. Die Feuerfeuerbindspunkt. Ach so, von Numenol und so. Er weiß es nicht. Er weiß es nicht. Er ist krank und ich nimm diesen Moment und stech so einen Speer in dich rein. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie die heissen, aber die Musik ist ganz toll. Naja, jedenfalls gibt es diese tolle Szene und das ist so ein bisschen genau das erste Signal, aber oft denke ich mir, das ist ja sehr früh und danach ist man drei Tage später doll krank. Da müsste es doch eigentlich ein Medikament geben, was man dann direkt reinballert. Wirklich so direkt so komplett bekämpfen, weil es ist ja schon verloren. Oder halt Vollnarkose. Also wir haben es ja schon lange vorgeschlafen für Flugreisen, dass du einfach während der Flugdasein narkotisiert bist, einfach sagen, hey, pass auf, die nächsten zwei Tage wären nicht schön, Vollnarkose und dann wachst du auf und dann ist es alles wieder. Kochsalzlösung, Feuer rein, ins Leuchtfeuer. Apropos Herr der Ringe, wir haben ja letztens debattiert, sprechen wir zu viel über Herr der Ringe. Und jetzt kam tatsächlich eine Rückmeldung aus der Communite und ich kann jetzt nicht Wort für Wort wiedergeben, ich paraphrasiere,, wird nicht stimmen, aber ich paraphrasiere jetzt. Und da hat jemand versucht einzugreifen in diese Diskussion. Herr der Ringe, ja oder nein? Ist es ein nerdiges Nischenthema oder ist es auch eine Art Servicefaktor, den wir bieten? Und die Person hat gesagt, ja, ich habe Herr der Ringe nie wirklich gemocht, war kein Fan, aber ihr habt darüber geredet und so die ganzen Sachen, Maura Labingi oder so, der eigentliche Westron-Name von Frodo Beutlin und all das haben wir darüber gesprochen und er meinte, er hätte sich letztens auf einer Party wiedergefunden, wo es anscheinend einige sehr eingefleischte Herr-der-Ringe-Fans gab, die er nicht kannte, aber die er auf der Party waren und gefachsimpelt haben und er konnte dann tatsächlich mitreden und hat gesagt, übrigens, kennt ihr das mit Maura Labingi, das eigentlich am Ende Frodo mit Maura Labingi hätte unterschreiben können. Und dann kam ein wunderschöner Satz und er meinte, die Gruppe war so beeindruckt, dass mir ihr Anführer die Hand gegeben hat. Nein. Und das fand ich ein so herzlichen Moment. Ganz viele Fragen. Das fand ich so einen schönen Moment. Und er meinte, er hat keine Ahnung von der Deringe. Und wir haben ihm das Wissen gegeben. Aber so ein sehr spezielles, nischiges Funfact. Mit dem er diesen Ehrenhandschlag erhalten hat. Und ich meine, das ist natürlich ein glorreicher Moment, den er so schnell nicht vergessen. Ganz, ganz toll. Wahrscheinlich ist er in einer Gruppe aufgenommen, in die er gar nicht rein will. Richtig. Das kennt man ja. Man will ja oft nicht Mitglied sein von den Gruppen, die einen als Mitglied wollen.
Genau. Aber das ist eine spannende Sache, weil ich erst mal frage mich, wie geht man durchs Leben, wenn man sein Wissen aus das Podcast-Ufo bezieht?
Ja. Also sehr nischig und sehr klein und sehr, sehr.
Du, ich sag mal so, Stephans Fick-Tipps werden seit vielen Jahren in deutschen Schlafzimmern durchaus gerne angewandt. So ist das nicht.
Aber ich mag auch diese Geste, dass jemand sagt, ey, ich respektiere dein Wissen, ich geb dir die Hand.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr schön. Jachlag fällig.
Fand ich sehr, sehr schön. Ja, mag ich auch. Ich habe mich ja mal, und das geht mir immer noch so, ich cringe mich in Grund und Boden, weil ich mich mal erinnere, dass ich nach einem Gespräch, was schon viel zu lange ging, dann erst wurden Namen ausgetauscht und ich habe dann die Hand ausgestreckt. Das heisst, da habe ich also quasi mitten im Gespräch das Fenster für eine förmliche Körper berühren sich Geste, der Begrüßung ist schon lange zu und ich strecke mitten im Gespräch wie ein Bürgermeister im Wahlkampf die Hände aus und sage, hallo Stefan, freut mich sehr, die Bekanntschaft zu machen und das ist natürlich albern und ich denke mir, bei jedem Dusche denke ich mir, oh fucking hell, holy shit, war das unangenehm, aber jetzt sagst du, nee, der Handschlag ist wieder am Start. Ich finde es aber auch aus einer Geste nicht in der Begrüßung, wo das Fenster schon zu wäre, sondern einer Geste der Wertschätzung. Ja, ich finde, ein Handschlag ist entweder eine komplett mechanisierte Begrüßungsgeste, ja, da ist nicht viel dahinter, man macht das einfach professionell, oder es ist genau das Gegenteil, eine wirkliche Respektsbekundung, die wirklich auch Gravitas hat, wo man wirklich sagt, so, jetzt der Handschlag und dann hat er auch ein Gewicht. Vor allem, wenn sich nicht alle in der Gruppe handschlagen. Man kennt das ja, wer mit wem, das ist dann wirklich so wie so ein Knoten, so eine Verwebung. Nicht überkreuze. Nicht überkreuze. Fuck you. Und dann hin und her. Die werden das rufen, fuck you. Und dann greifen drei Hände in einen und einer schüttelt alleine die Luft, wenn man sich denkt, jetzt bin ich hier, jetzt schüttel ich einfach die Luft, irgendwas muss geschüttelt werden. Er leckt auch so, er ist so halb in der Mauer drin und man denkt sich, was macht er ein? Viel zu weit über die Gruppe hinweg, es ist furchtbar. Aber wenn man wirklich zwei Leuten der Gruppe nochmal einen Handschlag gibt, schön. Hat du, ich weiß, du paraphrasiertest. Ich gebe es falsch wieder. Du gibst es alles falsch wieder, genau. Aber, du hast gesagt, der Anführer der Gruppe, das wird die spannende Beobachtung, weil erst mal, wie machst du in modernen Gruppen den Anführer, die Anführerin fest? Der Umhang, oder? Das Langschwert, der Zweihänder, wir wissen es nicht. Na klar, die Krone, es ist alles. Das Abzeichen auf den Schultern, ich glaube nicht. Aber ich glaube, es ist immer noch ein Instinkt, den jeder Mensch hat. Ich glaube, ich könnte dir jetzt ein Gruppenfoto zeigen. Das gefällt mir gar nicht. Du sagst ja zu all diesen Alpha-Man-Coaches. Ja. Kein Problem. Ich glaube, ich könnte dir jetzt noch ein Gruppenfoto zeigen und du kannst mir sagen, wer ist der Chef. Und du kannst mir auch sagen, wer ist der Dödel. Wen würdest du angreifen, wen würdest du opfern sofort? Immer der, der unten vor der Gruppe liegt. Ja, genau. Es gibt Leute, die sich so instinktiv ... Es war mal ein alter Tweet von mir. Ich recycle, es ist Krankheitsfolger, es wird nur alte Tweets recycelt. Du hast ja alle deine Tweets gelöscht, das heißt, ich kann ja niemand aufhalten. Habe ich nicht, ich habe meinen Account gelöscht. Alle Tweets sind weg, wurden letztens recherchiert versucht von der Reddit-Community, liebe Grüße, und nichts gefunden. Du bist wirklich ein unbeschriebenes Blatt. Du kannst nochmal bei null anfangen. Das irritiert mich, weil archive.org hat so alte, ganz viel unnötigen Kram, finde ich, wie ich beim Ausmisten eigentlich. Ich behalte dann so viel Qualität, wo man denkt, was, und dann, wo sind die Teller? Wo sind die grossen Teller hin? Wo ist das fucking Ladekabel für die Geräte, die ich jeden Tag benutze? Und stattdessen, ich habe noch die Zeitung vom Tag, an dem ich geboren wurde. Ja, neulich habe ich so Bettbezug weg, habe ich aussortiert. In welchem, bei welchem Zustand habe ich in Bettbezug aussortiert? Naja, so,
erstmal die Frage, wie wird der Gruppenanführer
bestimmt?
Dann gefällt mir auch, was sagen denn die
anderen, die da in der Gruppe waren, dazu, dass
du als Außenstehender gesagt hast
und dann hat der Anführer mir die Hand gegeben.
Ich glaube, da gibt es noch ein bisschen Redebedarf in der Gruppe.
Okay, du meinst, falls die Gruppe diese
Folge jetzt auch hört, dann wird
Moment, Justin ist doch nicht unser Anführer. Manfred ist doch unser Anführer, ich dachte, ich bin unser Anführer, ich dachte, wir haben keinen Anführer, ich dachte, wir sind die Demokratie, doch nicht seit dem Putsch letzte Woche, das kann natürlich jetzt zu unangenehm Fragen sein. Genau, da kommt die Putschwoche wieder hoch und so. Ach Gott, ja, als Ferdinand versucht hat, mit seiner Ski-WhatsApp-Gruppe die komplette Gruppe zu übernehmen. Und dann natürlich noch die Frage, wie krass kann das ein Herr-der-Ringe-Freundeskreis sein, wenn sie das nicht muss. Ja, naja, das stimmt. Wenn so ein Billo nicht Nerd, sondern cool Podcast, wie das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projekt, wenn das sogar noch Dinge beisteuern kann, die die eingefleischten Fans nicht kennen. Die These, wer sich eingefleischter Fan nennt, ist kein eingefleischter Fan. Ja, ja. Weil jeder, der richtig Fan ist, kennt mindestens acht Leute im Forum, im Reddit, die noch viel krassere Fans sind als man selber. Und man sagt, ach ja, ich schaue es ganz gerne so. Ich glaube, wenn du wirklich sagst, ich bin ein eingefleischter Fan, ich habe ein Hobbit-Poster mit mir zu Hause hängen, ich habe irgendwie den Zauberstab von Ginny Weasley an der Wand, bist kein echter Fan. Ja, auch da, ne, dann denke ich mir, haben wir auch mal die These aufgestellt, die Merch tragen von etwas, sind nicht wirklich Fan von dem. Das stimmt. Du machst Werbung. Wie gesagt, im Podcast Ufo Store, der Schal ist sehr bequem, mir geht es wirklich sofort besser, schönes Motiv, es ist wirklich klasse, man weiß, wo oben und unten ist. Ich habe mich für die Doppelschlinge entschieden, die allerdings immer wieder herunterfällt. Vielen Dank an Tim, der uns dieses fantastische Schalmotiv designt hat. Es kommt gut an, der Schal kommt gut an in der sehr kranken Podcast-Suche-Community. Das war natürlich ein wenig geplant von uns, dass wir eine gewisse Krankheit ja auch befeuern und sagen, geht ohne Mütze raus, geht mit nassen Haaren raus, sagen wir schon seit Jahren im Podcast. Ich habe vor allem gedacht, ja, ich habe euch gefragt, was soll das, schals. Ich dachte vor allem, dass unsere Community eher nicht rausgeht und deswegen eher gesund bleibt. Da bin ich im Irrtum aufgesessen, mal wieder. Genau, aber er ist ein recht beliebtes Merch-Item. Gebt uns da gerne mal Feedback. Genau wie die Kopfschmerztabletten, die gehen nicht weg. Also muss man echt sagen. Die Podcast-Ufo-Ebus. Die Ebus, es gibt einmal die Stephans, die sind ein bisschen stärker. Und dann die Florentins für die leichten Tage. Kriegt man hin. Ansonsten auch schön die Adrenalinspritzen, also alles, was ihr braucht. Deckt euch gerne ein. Wir sind keine Ärzte. Wir erinnern uns übrigens alle an die Geschichte, als ich das Tausenderpack Ibuprofen in New York. Also du benutzt heute den New York Hustensaft. Den Hustensaft, den ich mir damals am New Yorker Flughafen gekauft habe. Genau. Weil ich auf dem Heimflug schon dachte, oh, ich werde krank. Ich bin ja in New York krank geworden, könnt ihr gerne zurückspulen zur New York-Folge, da hört ihr mich wahrscheinlich ähnlich klingen. Das wollen die Leute hören, Folgen, wo Flutin krank ist. Ich glaube, es gibt eine kleine Sub-Community unter Podcast-Uferhörern, die sich nur die Folgen anhören, wo einer von uns krank ist. Die sagen, das sind die Besten. Die sagen, das sind die Besten, die sind gehalten. Weil da ist es ein bisschen ruhiger. Und man kann mal ein bisschen in die Fassade schauen, weil man nicht seine Verteidigung so hoch halten kann, weil man sehr krank und mit grossen Schmerzen ist. Und ja, der Hustensaft ist seit zwei Jahren abgelaufen, das hat mich jetzt nicht abgehalten, den runterzukippen. Ich weiß nicht, was Hustensaft genau ist, was der hilft, was der im Magen macht, das hilft. Ich glaube, es geht eher um den Weg nach unten, aber ich bin ein schneller Schlucker. Das habe ich schon in frühen Kindheitsjahren gemerkt, dass ich wirklich mit sehr, sehr hoher Geschwindigkeit schlucke. Wir fragen nicht, bei welchen Ereignissen du das herausgefunden hast. Vielen Dank an der Stelle für diesen kleinen Exkurs in den Kanal.
Also, was ich spannend finde.
Die Tausend Ibu, nämlich, so, aus New York.
Die sind jetzt tatsächlich wieder in meinem Leben.
Erstmal benutze ich die regelmäßig.
Wie viel hast du noch?
Hast du einen Überblick?
Ungefähr neunhundertachtzig.
Aber ich benutze die jetzt. Das sind meine Ibus. Einfach. So, und jetzt ist mir mal, und ich habe tatsächlich häufig Kopfschmerzen, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, die Spritze rausgeholt? So, du hast 20 Inventarplätze und in jedem ist ein Ibu-Profen. Ich habe die alle voll. Wo ist dein Schwert, wo ist der Heiltrank, kein Platz, musst du alles liegen lassen. Und häufig finde ich, so dann habe ich draußen wohl was gefunden, was ich gerne hätte, und dann muss ich nicht eine Ibu fallen lassen. Okay. Und dann kann ich das auch, weil ich stecke erstmal alles voll mit Ibus, meine ganzen 20 Inventarplätze. Das ist nicht dumm. Ich könnte diese scheiß Sidequests machen für mehr Inventarplätze, aber habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Das sage ich dir ganz ehrlich. Habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Was die alte Bäuerin dann mit ihren Hühnern macht, ist mir scheißegal. Ist mir scheißegal. Ich will den Drachen besiegen, die sollen mehr aus dem Weg gehen. So, dann habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Sag ich dir ganz ehrlich, habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Was die alte Bäuerin da mit ihren Hühnern macht, ist mir scheißegal.
Ist mir scheißegal.
Ich will einen Drachen besiegen, die sollen mir aus dem Weg gehen.
So, dann habe ich tatsächlich eine Ibu fallen lassen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es passiert ist.
Irgendwo draußen, bei mir vor der Wohnung, habe ich eine Ibu fallen lassen.
Dann war ich unterwegs.
Mein Handy war aus.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Ich glaube, ich war irgendwie so entspannt in der Sauna oder so.
Komm so zurück. Sorry, aber das Leben, das du führen musst, dass ein Saunabesuch so nebenbei stattfindet, da war ich irgendwie, ich glaube, das ist auch noch irgendwie so. Also wenn ich mal in der Sauna bin, dann ist es ein Jahrzehntereignis und ich habe danach Hausverbot und da erinnere ich mich dran. Und du weißt, wie man schluckt. Also, die, ja, ich war in der letzten Woche mal in der Sauna. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das das Ereignis war. Für die Story sagen wir jetzt einfach mal ja. Ich erinnere mich an den Saunabesuch, und so ist es nicht, es ist schon etwas, was besonders ist in meinem Leben. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt zusammenfiel. Wir machen es klar, wir machen es einfach. Ich kam aus der Sauna, gucke auf mein Handy und habe ungelogen 25 verpasste Nachrichten in der Anwohnergruppe. Uff, das ist selten ein gutes Zeichen. Es ist oft ein schlechter Zeichen. Also entweder es wird gegrillt oder es wird eingebrochen. Ja, oder Feuer oder bei uns immer Wasserschaden. Eigentlich wirklich in zehn von zehn Fällen Wasserschaden. Ich gucke rein, oh nein. Aber das erste Bild, ich scrolle hoch, das erste Bild ist ein Foto von meiner Ibu-Puffet. Wir erinnern uns auch, die sind nicht deutsch, langweilig, weiss, es steht Ibuprofen drauf, nein, die sind rot. Die sind rot und klein. Die New Yorker Ibus. Die New Yorker Ibus und die sehen aus wie, und da muss ich allen zustimmen, wie Ecstasy. Okay. So, und dann hat eine Nachbarin das gesehen, fotografiert vor der Formel und gesagt, was ist das, E-Fragezeichen? Das hat sie wahrscheinlich lange überlegt, Rewrites, noch mal Co-Autoren angefragt. Wie drücke ich jetzt aus, dass ich durchaus schon ein wenig Party-Erfahrung habe, trotzdem aber eine Distanzware zu diesen Substanzen? Ja, ich meine, sie hat sich bewogen gefühlt. Ich finde, für jemanden, die E sagt, alleine. Wir sind nicht bei Molly, okay, aber wir sind bei E. Für jemanden, die E sagt, finde ich es trotzdem einen krassen Move, das zu fotografieren und in die Gruppe zu stellen.
Aber ist das ein Versuch, cool zu sein oder ist das ein Versuch, zu verschlüsseln und die Spuren zu verwischen, dass man dir nicht nachweisen kann? Ja, ja. Ich fand es interessant und dann wirklich alle waren sehr irritiert, weil es ist jetzt auch kein öffentlich zugänglicher Bereich, wo ich das da liegen lassen oder wo es mir runtergefallen ist, sondern es ist ein Bereich, wo eigentlich nur die Anwohner hinkommen. Also es war so klar, entweder, ah, Jugendliche haben da oben bei uns eh konsumiert, das weiß jetzt niemand, Ibuprofen. Ja, um eine richtig geile Party auf der Terrasse zu feiern, wo nichts ist, ja, geil. Und die Jugendlichen nehmen Husten und sagen Ibu.
Ja, und dann war es so, viele Nachbarn sind eingestiegen und haben dann versucht, drauf zu entschlüsseln, weil da steht dann so ein I minus zwei.
Ich glaube, als jemand, der weiß, was das ist, das ist für Ibuprofen, 200 steht, also auch noch die schwächste Variante.
Jetzt hat aber das zu so regen Google-Suchanfragen geführt und dann haben sie wirklich, dann haben sie auch andere Tabletten gefunden und jetzt muss ich sagen, wirklich spannend, das eine war ein Abnehmenmittel, das andere war etwas gegen Angstzustände und das andere, vor allem, das sah sehr, sehr ähnlich aus, war ein Antidepressivum. Impressivo. Aha. Und dann, ja, wandte sich die Gruppe einig, ah, fuck, und ich, ehe ich dann quasi schreiben konnte, war sich die Gruppe schon darauf geeinigt, dass da wohl Antidepressivum gefunden wurde. Ich grätsche rein, sag, sorry um eure, dass ich eure ganzen Theorien zerstören muss, es ist eine Ibuprofen 200 aus New York. Und dann hatte der Anführer der Anwohnergruppe die Hand gegeben und gesagt, ja, du kennst dich aus. Ich hätte mir das gewünscht. Keine Anerkennung? Nein, es wurde eher so weggelacht. Ich glaube, die meisten haben mir das nicht geglaubt. Aber ist das denn Methode, also dass Medikamente ähnlich aussehen, dass man, also wenn man jetzt Antidepressiva nimmt, gibt es ja, sag ich mal, so eine Art Datenschutz. Ich will nicht, dass das jeder sofort sieht. Ist das die Idee, dass die aussehen wie andere Medikamente oder so?
Also, dass man die ähnlich aussehen lässt? Ich glaube eigentlich nicht. Ich glaube, Antibusierung ist
relativ heavy mit starken Nebenwirkungen.
Ich glaube, du willst nicht, dass du da
so zuhust als Instrument.
Ist ja so, dass wenn du jetzt, sage ich mal, irgendwie
Hardcore-Pornos bestellst im Internet, die dicken
Scheiben, die dicken Schallplatten,
wie die zwei Zentimeter dicken Schallplatten,
wo wirklich das gute Zeug drauf ist. Weil jeder weiß, die dicken Schallplatten, desto lauter oder länger, ich weiß nicht, je länger lang und dick. Und wenn du das richtig gute Zeug bestellst, dann kommt das ja auch in unscheinbaren Kästen an. Wo auch eine andere. Aber ich sag mal so, da hatte ich einen schönen Abend, das kann ich mir weiter empfehlen. Aber das Lustige finde ich ... Das sind die richtig guten Dinge. Also das Schlimme eigentlich, muss ich mich korrigieren, finde ich, dass die meisten, in den meisten Podcasts, in denen gesagt wird, ich bin krank, so als Entschuldigung vorangestellt, merkt man das den Leuten dann nicht an. Bei dir merkt man es ja auch nicht an, man hört es halt. Ah ja, mhm. Okay. Das finde ich von daher ... Bist du so ein Typ, der sagt, oh, du bist krank, bleib mir von der Pelle? Nee, mir ist das egal. Okay. Bis ich dann krank werde, dann werde ich rückblickend sauer. Aber ähm, genau, so, und dann war es so, dass in der Gruppe wurden dann so Nachrichten geschrieben, die mir dann nicht so gefielen, als jemand, der gerade gesagt hat, haha, Leute, es war ein Ibu, sorry, hab ich fallen lassen, weil danach kamen so viele Nachrichten rein, so, ach ja, interessant, wir hoffen, es geht allen im Haus gut, viel Gesundheit an alle Bewohner und so, das heißt, offensichtlich haben die meine Begründung nicht geglaubt, dass es E-Bus sind, sondern man hat sich jetzt darauf geeinigt, Stefan hat wollte nicht zugeben, er nimmt dann die Depressivung und es wurden dann so, ja, so Beileidsbekundungen ein bisschen ausgetauscht. Ja, das ist so, das war mir die E-Bus 200. Also ich meine, ist das denn angebracht, Beileidsbekundungen? Ich meine, das ist ja mittlerweile recht weit verbreitet, auch völlig in Ordnung. Und dann zu sagen, also wie reagiert man darauf? Beileids ist es auch nicht, aber sie haben so gesagt, wir hoffen, es geht allen im Haus gut. Was jetzt eine
andere Reaktion wäre,
finde ich, wenn sie meinen, es sind einfach
Ibuprofen, es ist Kopfschmerzverbleiben.
Ja, ja. Ist eine extrem allgemeine
Aussage, wir hoffen, es geht allen gut.
So, ich glaube, je
allgemeiner Aussagen, desto verletzender können sie auch sein.
Ich finde diese Aussage sagt ganz klar,
ja, Stefan, right.
Ja, Stefan, wir wissen, wir nimmst Viagra und sonstiges sieht alles gleich aus. Oh Mann. Ja, gut, aber das ist jetzt so weit es gekommen. Aber das wäre eigentlich eine schöne Folge. Du hast so zehn Tabletten dabei und verlierst die überall, auch in der Sauna. Und überall gibt es so ein Drama rundum und jede Gruppe nimmt es anders wahr. Für die eine Gruppe ist es automatisch E, für die andere ist es Viagra und so und dann hast du in jeder Gruppe ein anderes Problem. Gute zwölf Minuten eigentlich, kannst du eine gute Folge rausmachen, Rig and Morty oder sowas oder Roseanne, also schreibe ich dir runter. Roseanne. Schreibe ich dir runter. Ich bin übrigens wieder zu haben, also 50 Euro schreibe ich euch einen Text, ich bin Künstler, ich bin Autor, ich bin DJ. Wofür? Ich schreibe euch einen Text runter, kein Problem. Gedicht, Limerick, Ballade, überhaupt kein Problem. Wo kommt das jetzt her? Ich habe einen Schal um, ich kann schreiben. Ach, der Schal. So schwer wird es doch nicht sein, das kriege ich doch hin, ist doch kein Problem. Nein, ist der Schal. Ich schreibe das runter. Ich habe ja, ich war jetzt in Berlin, da ist nämlich die Berlinale ja gewesen. Da war ich. Hast du gewonnen? Hast du gewonnen, mein Sohn? Es lief nichts da. Hast du gewonnen, mein Sohn, oder bist du wieder mit leeren Händen nach Hause gegangen? Nein, Papa, von mir lief da nichts. Ich bin dann, also ich war einfach nur da. Ach, da lief nicht mal was. Und warum warst du dann da? Naja, viele so Empfänge und Treffen am Rande der Berlinale-Stadt. Ah, Empfänge, dafür reicht's, okay. Nee, ich hab dir doch gesagt, das ist halt ein langfristiges Projekt, aber um da was machen zu können, muss ich erst mal stattfinden, oder muss ich auf diesen Empfängen sein und Leute kennenlernen und Leute treffen, mit denen ich meine Projekte umsetzen kann. Und die sind halt nun mal alle da. Ich hab dir damals die Sitcom angeboten. Roxanne. Ja, Roxanne. Richtig. Nee, Roxanne. Und Match. Und Match. Und du hast alles abgelehnt, weil du dir zu gut warst, wenn du Künstler, du Auteur sein wolltest. Und jetzt, wo bist du Auteur? Ja, aber das waren alles Serien, die so ähnlich waren wie Sachen, die es schon gibt. Naja, man muss darauf aufbauen, was funktioniert. Totschlagargument, finde ich. Du hast mir Sachen angeboten, die es schon gibt.
Du machst es nicht so aus dem Mundwinkel, so
ja doch, eigentlich muss man das machen, ne.
Man muss die Mund zusammenziehen.
Wir sind wahrscheinlich immer die gleiche Seite, ne?
Bei mir ist es links.
Bei dir ist es was?
Bei mir ist es auch links, die Rechtsseite,
also es ist die Seite,
es ist die Seite, wo du auch mit blinzelst.
Sehr gut, ja, wo man blinzelt, ich kann auch nur links blinzeln. Ja, und da machst du auch, das heißt, es ist genau wie bei mir, die eine Hälfte ist zu was zu gebrauchen und die andere ist komplett weg. Jetzt dann, in Klammer auf, ich finde auch geil, wenn man eine Studie machen würde, emotionale, rationale Menschen, wer kann am ehesten linksbleiben bleiben. Oder halt anders als die Händigkeit, wenn du Rechtshänder bist, dann ist dein Gesicht, bist linksgesichtig, ja linksgesichtig aber die Augenbrauen, bei Augenbrauen geht bei mir gar nichts also die Augenbrauen haben sich früh abgemeldet das ist wirklich wie so Latein, wo du irgendwie nach einer Woche merkst, es wird nichts mit Augen trainiere ich auch kaum, bin total hinterher mit meinem Augenbrauen Training, stimmt ich habe überhaupt keinen Ausdruck, ich habe null Ausdruck in den Augenbrauen, es gibt ja manche Leute, die haben wirklich, da passiert einiges. Okay, es wäre nur wichtig, dass wenn du aufhörst zu sprechen, dass es davor irgendein Anzeichen gibt, dass es plötzlich vorbei ist, sonst kann ich auch nicht so sonst bin ich genauso überrascht wie du. Ja, ich muss sagen, du hast genau wie ich auch Augenbrauen, die jetzt nicht so präsent sind im Gesicht. Das stimmt, ja. Es gibt ja so wunderschöne Männer mit so wunderschönen, dichten Augenbrauen, die so wahnsinnig charakterkrass sind. Ich glaube, die machen automatisch mehr, weil die denken, ja, damit macht man was. Das ist halt wie so ihr Instrument. Bei uns beiden, wir haben beide nicht so präsente Augenbrauen. Ich glaube, bei uns sind die, wir sind nicht damit groß geworden, dass es ein Stilmittel ist, mit dem wir unsere Sachen ... Vielleicht haben wir es auch nicht genug trainiert. Also, ich war ja früher dann doch auf dem Weg, ein richtig guter Mensch zu werden. Wann war das? Das ist schon eine Weile her. Schön Nintendo DS. Aber da kannten wir es noch nicht, oder? Da kannten wir es noch nicht. Nintendo DS, Doktor Kawashimans Brain Training. Habe ich jeden Tag gemacht, Brain Training, jeden Tag acht plus eins.
Mehr als acht.
Und mehr als eins.
Und da habe ich trainiert und dann dachte ich mir natürlich, okay, was kommt
als nächstes? Mein Gehirn ist trainiert, mein Gehirn
steht im Saft, ist saftig und fruchtig
und lecker und ich habe ein richtig leckeres Gehirn.
Das könntest du richtig aussauen.
Das könntest du aussauen.
Das ist ein schönes, leckeres Gehirn. Und dann der zweite Teil, Doktor Kawashimas Gesichtstraining. Also nach dem Gehirn kommt das Gesicht. Das heißt, du hast dann dein Nintendo DS vor dich gehalten. Und machst die Nasenflügel. Und machst die Nasenflügel und die Augenbrauen hoch. Und da habe ich mir gesagt, nee, brauche ich nicht. Mein Gesicht ist ausreichend ausdrucksstark. Hätte ich damals mehr Zeit investiert,
hätte ich vielleicht heute ein ausdrucksstarkeres Gesicht und du könntest mir besser von den Lippen ablesen, was ich will. Ich kann, glaube ich, gut ablesen, gerade was du willst von deinen Lippen. Schlaf und mehr Hustensache. Ja, richtig. Gut. Ich lese fliessend Lippen. Ä, Berlinale und ich bin nicht, also für coole Storys habe ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, bin nicht in den Kreisen. Du hast doch bestimmt Shrimps gegessen, oder? Aber, keine Shrimp, keine Shrimp, ich, aber was ich sagen kann, der Einblick für diese Ecken hinter den Kulissen, in die eh niemand rein will.
Und ihr nie reinkommt.
Man wird krank. Nach der Berlinale
und das ist die erste Berlinale, nachdem ich nicht krank bin.
Weil sonst wurde ich immer auch krank, weil
das ist wirklich so eine Petrischale, weil das
immer die gleichen Leute auf den
gleichen Empfängen.
Wie gesagt, das sind diese Kreise,
da, ich glaube nicht, dass man, dass die
Tom Tücker ist wie so ein Gartensprenger mit ein paar Zehen, wirklich. Ttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttt ich wünsche dir viel Erfolg auf deinem Weg. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum du das immer so dismissive abtust. Dabei habe ich doch extra so ganz bescheiden jetzt gesagt, dass ich nicht mit Tom Tickwa auf der Feier bin, sondern auf den Nebenfeiern und da Also diese mehrstrangige Handlungsebene, ich fand das so toll. Also ich fand das so interessant, wie die Charaktere gleichzeitig nebeneinander, aber auch hintereinander existiert haben. Für mich ist Cloud Atlas wirklich ein unfassbar guter Film. Es tut mir leid, dass ich da jetzt, ich kann jetzt nicht gegen Tom Tick war, vielleicht muss ich noch mal irgendwann was, weißt du, wenn der mich fragen würde, ob ich dem Cloud Atlas 2 schreibe. Ja, okay. Hell fucking yes. Würdest du machen? Ja. Und dann, die Frage ist, wann in dem Prozess gebe ich zu, dass ich den Film nicht verstanden habe? Tom Tick war, ich mache es billiger. Für 50 Euro schreibe ich dir den ersten Entwurf, kein Problem. 90 Minuten, 90 Seiten schreibe ich dir runter in zwei Tagen, überhaupt kein Problem. Cloud Atlas, ist doch kein Problem. Wolken, kannst du so viel darüber erzählen. Es gibt Leute, es gibt Krisen, die ernähren sich von Wolken, die laufen durch die Wolken und fressen die Wolken auf. Ja, hast du schon mal 20 Seiten? Ja, vielen Dank, dass Sie mich treffen in meinem Palast, in meinem Tücker-Palast. Irgendwie habe ich so einen Kratzen im Hals, Herr Tigwa. Vielen Dank für die, ja, man nennt mich den Gartensprenger der Bazillen. Kurz eine Frage zu Ihrer ersten Fassung. Also ich fange mal oben an direkt. Erste Szene. Interior, Studienraum Tag, ein Mann blättert im Wolkenatlas.
Genau, das ist sehr, haben Sie den ersten Film gesehen? Ich habe Clips davon gesehen, aber ich dachte, wenn du was erzählen willst, musst du direkt mit dem Arsch ins Gesicht vom Publikum springen. Also du musst direkt wirklich, ich sag immer so, die meisten Drehbuchautoren, vor allem in Hollywood, die haben einen Gürtel an. Ich hab keinen Gürtel an, bei mir ist die Hose schnell unten. Und die wissen, was das bedeutet. Hose runter, Arsch ins Gesicht, direkt rein. Die Leute kaufen sich für viel, viel, viel Geld. Ein Kinoticket und gehen rein und wollen Cloud Atlas sehen. Und ich sag, ich geb ihnen genau das, was sie wollen, ja, Cloud Atlas, so, hast du direkt auf der ersten Seite, Cloud Atlas und dann guckt er, wo sind die Wolken? Ja, wo sind die Wolken und dann sieht er hier da, sind die Wolken und dann wird er sich groß erklärt, K für Columbus Nimbus Wolken, S Schlieren Wolken, also aber die ersten 20 Seiten sind halt, wie er in diesem Wolkenatlas blättert.
Aber wenn ihm auffällt, also er unterschreibt ja auch, er unterschreibt ja das in der Recherche, er unterschreibt, wo er war, unterschreibt er mit Flerk Ruben.
Flerk Ruben.
Und das ist sein eigentlicher Name, weil in der Welt gibt es sozusagen unterschiedliche Sprachensysteme.
Ja, er spricht eine andere Sprache, aber das versteht es nicht.
Die Leute nennen ihn Paule, aber sein eigentlicher Name ist Flerergruben und das ist quasi in einer anderen Welt der Wolkenriesen. Wir melden uns dann. Wir melden uns bei Ihnen. Vielen Dank. Bringt ihn raus. Kann ich mich irgendwo hinlegen? Bringt ihn in den Krankenflügel. Ich glaube, ich muss mir übergeben. Bringt ihn in den Krankenflügel. Ey, Tom Tück war, ey, sie bat zehn Schleuder Tom Tück war. Wie ich sage, euren Kindern lassen sich von Tom Tück war fernhalten sollen. Generell, ja. Der Land ist ein wandelnder Krankheitsbaum, wirklich das ist der Untergang. Vielleicht eine der vier Reiter der Apokalypse. Die Leute sagen immer, oh, in der Bibel steht, Jesus kommt zurück. Richtig, in der Bibel steht aber auch, dass die vier fucking Reiter der Kapolippe zurückkommen. Und dann sollte man auch wirklich mal bei Statister nachfragen, wie das eigentlich ist.
fünf Minuten.
Man sollte eigentlich auch mal bei Statistern nachfragen.
Stopp mal ganz kurz.
Vier Reiter der Apokalypse und ein Jesus.
Welche Wahrscheinlichkeit ist grösser,
wer zuerst zurückkommt? Ich setze auf die Reiter.
Warum? Vier Reiter der Apokalypse und ein Jesus. Welche Wahrscheinlichkeit ist grösser, wer zuerst zurückkommt? Ich setze auf die Reiter, 50 auf die Reiter, weil die mehr sind, weil die mehr sind. Und vielleicht ist Tom Tücker, es gibt ja Krankheit, Krieg, Hunger und Social Media und ich glaube, Tom Tücker ist Krankheitsreiter. Hier hört ihr es zuerst, Tom Tück war der erste Reiter der Apokalypse.
So, beschwert euch nicht, wenn ihr euch irgendwie im Hals hängt mit Masern.
Ich habe es euch gesagt, haltet euch fern von dem Mann, der ist nichts Gutes für euch. Und Cloud Atlas ist ein beschissener Film. Die sieben Todsünden sind Töten, Völlerei, Insta-Bilder von vor 50 Jahren, die schon sehr alt sind, liken, in einem Meeting zuerst sagen, wir stellen uns jetzt erstmal alle vor, wir machen einen Icebreaker. Ich finde, die Todsünden wurden lange nicht mehr aktualisiert. Ja, wirklich. Ich meine, sowas wie Lust. Ich sage, und da möchte ich jetzt auch zitiert werden, Frankfurter Allgemeine aufgepasst, wir leben in einer lustlosen Gesellschaft. Du willst mehr Lust? Ich will mehr Lust, ich will mehr Schweiss, ich will mehr Körper, Säfte, ich will mehr Körper, Löcher, ich will mehr Körper, Unreinheiten, ich will Kurven, ich will Säcke, ich will Fülste, ich will Unreinheiten. Ich bin kurven. Ihr wolltet Florentin anmaskt, ihr habt Florentin anmaskt. Ich dachte nur, ich plädier seit Jahren für eine Maske. Ich will seit Jahren die Fassade. Ihr wollt hinter die Fassade blicken. Ich sag, lass nicht mal, vor der Fassade. Wir haben uns das schön gemütlich gemacht, vor der Fassade. Du willst, ihr wollt hinter die Kulissen gehen. Ich will, dass ihr euch verknotet. Ihr wisst nicht, wie es da aussieht. Ich will, dass ihr euch verknotet. Ich will, dass ihr euch zusammendrückt. Manchmal ist dieinander gedrückt. Kulissen haben was sehr, sind zwar kulissenhaft, gut, aber wir mögen es da als Menschheit sehr gern. Nee, nee, nee, jetzt müssen wir rauskommen. Setzt euch schön den Fickhut auf und legt los. Wir müssen ran, wir müssen uns gegenseitig verknoten. Florentins Ficktipps, Tipps, Tipps, Tipps. Randa, randa. Titz, titz. Aber wie bist du auf der Berlinale? Also bist du dann wirklich so ein kleiner Schwimm? Ich wollte nur sagen, alle werden da krank, weil die Petrischale Berlin ist, die Petrischale Deutsch. Du mit krummem Rücken wandelst da durch die Gänge und sagst, äh, Herr Polanski, ich mag Ihre Werke so gern, Herr Polanski, Herr Polanski, so. Herr Schweiger, ich liebe Ihre Muse, ich liebe Ihre Muse. Ich bin gespannt, wie viele noch gecancelte Regisseure dir einfallen, aber ja. Woody Allen, Woody Murphy. Aber jetzt mal unter uns, hat Berlin wirklich was mit den Bären zu tun? Oder ist es so ein schlechter Gag mit irgendwie Bärbel und Hubschraubär und sowas? Linder, Bärbel und Linder, die die Stadt damals gegründet haben, wie Romulus und Remus. Bärbel und Linder, die bei einem Käffchen und bei einem schönen Stück Frankfurter Kreuz, Frankfurter Kranz, wie alle einfach gesagt haben, pass doch mal auf, der hat sich gerade ins Gesicht geschlagen. Und wie hießen die Romulus und Remus? Nee, Bärbel und Linda. Ja, ja. Aber jetzt hör mal zu, du ich hab eine Idee. Was hältst du denn von? Wir gründen eine Stadt. Linda, sagst du dir, wie es ist? Ich will keine Stadt, ich will kein Dorf, ich will hier mein Berliner Kindel trinken und dann bin ich zufrieden. Aber Bärbel, jetzt sagst du was, Berliner Kindel, hör mal, das ist doch nicht schlecht. Das ist doch unser Bier. Das ist doch unser Bier. Ja, na klar ist das unser Bier. Ja, aber warum Berliner Kindel, Berlin gibt's ja gar nicht. Nee, aber für Bärbel und Linda. So. Weißt du, ich sag dir, wie es ist. Dieses Bier trinke ich und trinke ich und ich will das jetzt hier. Und ich brauche da keine Stadt, ich brauche da keine U-Bahn, ich brauche da keine Freundlichkeit. Du bringst mich gerade auf der Idee, Bärbel, sag ich ja mal gleich, du bringst mich auf der Idee. Warum gründen wir nicht hier und jetzt und heute, jetzt hier schön bei dem Frankfurter Kranz, warum können wir nicht hier direkt eine Stadt gründen? Na was spricht dagegen? Was spricht denn dagegen? Wir können doch mal schön eine Stadt gründen oder nicht? Wir Beude! Wir können einfach hier, mir nichts, dir nichts. Eine Stadt, eine Gründe. Ich kann nicht so viel lachen, Stefan, tut mir leid. Kann ja sein. Aber mal ganz kurz, Romulus und Remus haben Rom gegründet. Richtig, und Romulus ... Aber hat Remus nie gesagt, ich wäre für Rem? Wahrscheinlich, ja, aber komm, Rem. Hm? Naja, also ... Rema. Naja, die Stadt heisst Romulus. Das Rom steht für mich und das Ulus steht für dich. Ich falle halt komplett hinten rüber. Du weisst doch, Remus, du bist ja Hünn im Us mit drin. Aber auf Italienisch heisst es Roma. Ja. Ja, ja, aber es hat nur von dir alles drin. Romulus. Naja, komm, Rehm. Rehm. R-E-M, R-E-M. Rehm. Jetzt bringst du mich ja gerade auf eine Italien gerade. Ihr habt ja recht. Nee, ich kann sein, dass es vom Berg kommt. Ich glaube nicht. Ja, nee, da werden immer alle krank. Ist crazy, weil die alle anschreien und sich gegenseitig in die Münder husten und niesen. Aber ist es dann auch so ein Zeichen, dass man Teil der High Society ist, dass man in der Woche nach der Berlinale krank ist? Das heißt, auch die Leute, die jetzt nicht hingegangen sind, wie zum Beispiel ich, ich habe kein Ticket mehr bekommen, bin kein gefeierter Autor, obwohl ich einen Schal trage. ich könnte jetzt nach der in der Woche so tun, als wäre ich krank, sag irgendwelche Live-Termine ab und alle aus der Business, Tom Tücker liest das und denkt, ah, das ist einer von uns, dieser Florentin, das ist einer von uns. Das Wichtige ist, sich nach der Berlinale in Zoom-Meetings zu setzen und zu sagen, ich halte mich zurück, ich müte mich, ich bin hier eh raus, sorry, ich bin super krank. Es war so anstrengend wieder, wir haben so viele, es war so viele Meetings los, es war so viel los. Ich würde mich heute mal muten, ich würde mich mal muten, wenn es okay. Ja, und sich dabei so viel zu viel Raum nehmen, während man das so erklärt. Ich würde mich heute mal muten, wenn es geht. Wisst ihr was, es war so viel los und ich habe so viele Leute gedrungen, meine Stimme ist weg, seitdem ich war auf der Berlinale und ich sage euch, da habe ich dem Ton Tücker, ich habe gesagt, Herr Tücker, und dann lehnt er sich zurück, holt Luft und husse mir in den Mund und ich habe richtig den Schleimbrocken reingekommen. Ich habe richtig den Schleimbrocken reingekommen. Da hat er meine Augen so aufgerissen, hat er so aufgerissen wie bei Clockwork Orange und hat dann jeweils reingespuckt. Und ich konnte nur noch sagen, ich liebe Cloud Atlas, bevor ich zu Boden gegangen bin. Ist aber tatsächlich so, ich habe gelernt, früher war Zucker ja das beliebte Gut, alle wollten Zucker, Zucker war teuer. Definiere früher. Vor sechshundert Jahren, zweihundert, dreihundert Jahren, achtzehntes Jahrhundert, sagen wir mal so. Siebzehntes, achtzehntes Jahrhundert, grenzen wir mal nicht näher ein. Und da kam Zucker vor allem natürlich rüber aus China, wie Tee und so. Und die Leute haben natürlich gerne Tee getrunken und haben da Zucker eingebaut. Seit wann sagst du das so? Seit wann sagst du China so? Ja, seitdem ich meine bayerische Herkunft verschleiern möchte. Es sind Maulwürfel hinter mir her, die versuchen mein Leben zu infiltrieren. Haut ab. Und Leute, die viel Zucker konsumiert haben, haben schlechte Zähne bekommen. Also war es irgendwann schick, schlechte Zähne zu haben. Und die Leute haben angefangen, sich die Zähne schwarz anzumalen, um so zu wirken, als hätten sie Zugang zu Zucker. Ob das jetzt eine billige Werbegeschichte der Zuckerindustrie ist, ja oder nein, das weiß ich nicht. Mein Onkel kauft seit Jahren Zuckeraktien, weil er sagt, die Leute werden immer Zucker essen. Und er, finde ich, hat damit wirklich einen süßen Punkt getroffen, Sweetspot. Er hat was erwischt, weil tatsächlich Zucker ist nicht mehr wegzudenken. Gut, all diese ganzen Süßstoffe und Ersatzprodukte, die es heutzutage in Unmengen gibt. Zucker ist sehr, sehr billig, ja. Unglaublich billig. Aber das stimmt ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen der Satz Dress like the person you want to be. Don't dress like the person you already are. Ja, ich wäre gern Cäsar. Das ist natürlich jetzt diese Toga ist natürlich, weil es ist ja für ein Traum. Ich habe gefragt, wo sehen Sie sich in fünf Jahren? Und Sie haben gesagt, gut, ich kann mich kann mich nicht wie Caesar anziehen. Ich würde gerne den römischen
Senat stürmen, putschen
und mich selbst zum alleinigen Herrscher erklären.
Wie ein Terrorist oder sowas.
Terroritas
terroritatem, sage ich da oft.
Ja, das Ding ist,
das Ding ist, ich muss Sie
vorwarnen, die Toga ist
ein alleiniges Kleidungsstück,
ich trage nichts drunter.
Ich dachte, das sollten Sie wissen, falls Sie gleich nach mir die Treppe hochgehen, möchte ich Sie darauf vorbereiten, dass Sie eventuell Ihre Okuli abwenden. Meine Okulele? Ihre Okuli, ich glaube Augen, sagt man auch. Ich glaube. Das ist ja immer geil, so wie diese Leute, die zwei Wochen in Amerika waren und anfangen, das alles auf Englisch zu sagen. Ich war ja im Vatikan. Ich war ja im Vatikan und dann so sagen, wie sagt man auf Deutsch, die Götter? Deus de Domini. Ja, dem Papst geht es ja ganz schlecht. Malus. Malus, Mali, Malus, dem geht's ja ganz schlecht. Kann man jetzt für den Papst beten? Hast du da angesteckt? Wir waren ja auf der Berlinale. Naja, er kam auf mich zu, meinte, er ist Riesenfan von Die Unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von, hab ich ihm eine Halsguse, geb ich ganz ehrlich zu. Und dann ging's rapide bergab. Weil du so erschrocken warst, weil noch niemand den Satz gesagt hat zu dir, ich war so ein grosser von dir und wahrscheinlich ein Ereignis im Leben. Richtig, ja. Aber kann man jetzt für den Papst beten oder wer das anmassen? Weil der Papst betet ja für dich. Oh nein. Kannst du auch für ihn oder wer, also das ist ja die Dinge. Wir beten alle für den Papst. Der Papst betet für alle, wer betet für den Papst? Das ist nicht so ein Aufkampfsrager. Genau, niemand fragt den Papst, wie es ihm geht. Genau, ja. Deswegen fragen wir hier offiziell Papst, hey, alles okay? Alles gut, du kannst jederzeit mit uns reden. Alles okay. Ach, jetzt lächel doch mal wieder. Ach, jetzt musst du doch nicht traurig sein. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der Papst, und deswegen fand ich die Serie The Young Pope auch so toll, weil natürlich leben die auch im Jahre 2025 technologisch. Jetzt ist aber dieser ganze Raum und wo die da abhängen und so und alles ist so durchtraditionalisiert und vermutlich ist es noch genauso viel, wie es irgendwie vor 200 Jahren der Papst da gelebt hat, mit den Klamotten. Immun gegen Hackerangriffe, ne? Ich glaube, als Hacker beißt du dir am Vatikan echt die Zähne aus. Wegen der Schweizer Garde.
Wegen der Schweizer Garde. Wegen der Schweizer Garde, ja. Die haben eine Firewall-Jesus. Nee, weil die so alte Handys haben, so alte Knochen. So alte Prügel, so Autotelefone, kommen sie nicht durch. Nee, aber weißt du, was ich meine? Irgendwie finde ich es lustig, dass ich den Papst ... Also, sorry, sorry, falsche Wortwahl. Ich finde es spannend, sich den Papst vorzustellen im Krankenhaus an so einer Herz-Lungen-Maschine,
wo ich mir persönlich nicht vorstellen
kann, dass da irgendwie,
das finde ich auch in der Kirche,
in der alten Kirche, wo ich immer mit meiner Familie
Weihnachten war, stand, waren immer so
Lautsprecher und da stand, die waren
so steinmässig, dass die nicht
auffallen in der Kirche,
dass die in dem Schiff, in dem man sitzt,
komisches Wort für einen Raum,
der sich nicht bewegt, also
Du bist ja auch. so steinmässig, dass die nicht auffallen in der Kirche, dass die in dem Schiff, in dem man sitzt, komisches Wort für einen Raum, der sich nicht bewegt, also wirklich gar nicht bewegt, geschweige denn über Wasser. Und dann sind da diese Lautsprecher in der gleichen Steinoptik wie diese Säule aus dem Jahre 600. Und da steht unten drauf aber trotzdem Philips. In der gleichen Typo steht unten drunter Philips. Aber I guess it's the Stein Version.
Aber Philips ist zumindest noch ein Name, der in der Bibel eine Relevantnis hat. Samsung nicht so ideal.
Huawei.
Huawei, da kommst du irgendwie nicht gut mit rum. Ist schon schwierig. Kommt man nicht so gut mit rum. Genau. Und deswegen frage ich mich, wie sieht die Herz-Lungmaschine oder sagen wir mal, ich weiß nicht, so ein Infusionsbeutel, wie sehen die aus im Vatikan? Wie du sagst, Vatikan, wie sehen die da aus? Oder ist man konsequent und sagt, ja, wenn Gott diese Krankheit für mich entschieden hat, dann ziehe ich das jetzt auch durch. Da musst du natürlich aufpassen. Aber ich meine, wir wünschen ihm alles Gute, aber die Papstwahl ist schon auch immer unterhaltsam. Ja, der Film Conclave habe ich noch nicht gesehen, ist ganz oben auf meiner Liste. Nicht spoilern, bitte. Ich weiß noch nichts drüber. Bitte nicht spoilern. Aber ich freue mich riesig auf den Film Eddie Berger, deutscher Regisseur, unser Regisseur in Hollywood. Was sagen wir dazu? Ich liebe ja Conclave, Herr Berg. Ich liebe ja Conclave, Herr Berger. Du stehst da wie so ein kleiner Shrimp.
Ich bin der kleinste Shrimp auf dem ganzen Empfang.
Konklave ist natürlich auch so ein Film, wo man schwer Motivation findet, ihn anzuschauen, wo du sagst, so jetzt habe ich Bock auf so eine düstere Vatikan-Stein-Marmor-Nummer.
What, what, was, was? Ich will gute Laune, Freeming, ich will Lilo und Stitch, ich will Lilo und Stitch, Lilo et Stitch, will ich sehen, Lilo und Stitch will ich sehen. Ja, schwierig. Nee, ich finde das ja super. Ich finde gerade, wir, als die grossen Robert-Langton-Fans, als die grossen Dan-Brown-Fans, haben doch Bock auf Konklave-Stories, mehr Konklave-Stories. Ich kriege nicht genug Konklave-Stories. Alles, was in der sextinischen Kapelle spielt, sign me up, bitch. Sign me up für die sextinische Kapelle. Ich weiss nicht, ob man so mit dem Heiligen Geist reden darf, ehrlich gesagt. Sign me up. Wir haben es verstanden, ja. Sign me the fuck up. Schau es dir an, schau es dir an, Conclava, und sag mir, ob es gut ist, denn ich vertraue deinem Filmschmack. Das ist für Oskas-Nominiker wie Emilia Perez. Das fand ich sehr spannend, ich habe es noch nicht gesehen. Musicals kommen zurück ins Mainstream-Kino. Wie viele deiner Filme sind für Oscars nominiert? Papa, kein Film. Ich habe mir jetzt mal die Liste angeguckt, und da habe ich irgendwie gar nicht den Namen Stefan Tietze gesehen. Ja, aber wie du merkst, sind sehr wenige Menschen auf der Welt überhaupt nur
für den Oscar nominiert und ich verstehe nicht,
warum ist das ein Ziel,
der ist auch dieses Jahr, glaube ich, nicht nominiert.
Was ist das für ein Ziel?
Warum muss ich denn dann in Oscar nominiert?
Ich mache so Filme aus Spars und mich künstler, das zu verwirklichen.
Na gut, weil ich dachte, als du gesagt hast,
du willst nicht Roxanne schreiben,
dass du stattdessen vielleicht was schreiben würdest,
was einigermassen erfolgreich wäre, aber hast du ja nicht gemacht. Güte, du wirst mich lieben für das, was ich mache und nicht für deine Version von Erfolg. Ich wünsche, du würdest wertschätzen, was ich alles für dich geleistet und geopfert habe. Ich habe die Rechte für Roxanne gekauft für viele, viele hundert Euro. Viele, viele hundert. Unzählige, unzählige hundert Euro. Willst du wissen, wie viel es war? Acht hundert Euro. Es ist nicht unzählig. Acht hundert Euro. Ich finde das Wort unzählig. Acht hundert Euro habe ich ausgegeben von unserem Geld. Von unserem Geld. Wieso von unserem Geld? Was für ein Konto haben wir gemeinsam? Von unserem Geld habe ich acht Euro ausgegeben. Für die Rechte von Roxanne. Also hast du gesagt, 400 Euro ausgegeben. Mein Sohn ist Drehbuchautor, der will Autor werden. Ja. So wie Dan Brown. Und dann habe ich gesagt, gut, Roxanne ist es. Roxanne, du meinst ... Du hast keine Zeile für Roxanne. Roxanne meintest du, du hast dich vertan. Das ist, du hast keine Zeile für Roxanne geschrieben. Ich habe einen Film versucht zu schreiben, der Rock ... Papa, leg dich wieder hin. Du bist todkrank. Ich habe noch zwei Wochen zu leben. Was? Und was mich wirklich vielleicht noch mal glücklich machen würde, wäre zu sehen, dass du eine Folge Roxanne schreibst. Ah, okay. Nur eine Folge. Ich dachte, du meinst, was ich wirklich glücklich machen würde, wenn ich den Oscar gewinnen würde, weil das ist jetzt schwierig in zwei Wochen. Das meine ich ehrlich. Da bin ich ehrlich. Aber das andere kriege ich hin mit ChatGPT. Mit ChatGPT oder Claude. Warte, ich breche jetzt zusammen. Das tut mir leid, Frau Nudin. Aber weißt du, wo du das her hast? Das interessiert mich ja. Ich habe eine Vermutung. Ich will jetzt hier keinen Namen nennen. Tiengade. Wo das herkam, Krankheiten gehen um, es ist unklar, woher sie kommen, ob sie vielleicht staatsgesteuert sind oder nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine gezielte Attacke auf dem Podcast oder auf mich als Person. Kann ich jetzt schon sagen, nee, es ist nicht staatsgesteuert. Es gibt Leute, die wollen mich aus dem Weg sehen, es gibt diverse Firmen, die haben es auf mich abgesehen, die haben ihr feuriges Auge feuriges Auge auf mich geworfen. Und ich halte dagegen, gerade noch so.
Todsünde Nummer fünf wäre übrigens, krank zu Arbeit kommen.
Okay.
Weil man Leute ansteckt.
Da schaue ich auf dich, da schaue ich auf Herrn Gardet,
da schaue ich apathisch in Menschenmengen.
Schaust du auch in den Spiegel? apathisch in Menschenmengen.
Schaust du auch in den Spiegel?
Nein.
Du hast gar keinen Spiegel in deiner Wohnung.
Nein, ich habe gar keinen Spiegel in meiner Wohnung.
Ich kann mich nicht selber angucken.
Bist du ein Vampir?
Aber er war ein Vampir.
Sing jetzt ganz viel ein, weil du hast so eine schöne Stimme. Und er sang für Kabel vier, dort lief eine gute Show, mit Linda zerwarg es uns Mudon. Es ging um eine Frau, die fand sich in einer Welt, die ihr nicht gefällt, doch was soll sie nur tun, es ist eine einsame Frau, was soll sie nur tun, niemand hört auf sie, niemand hört auf sie, ihr Name ist Roxanne, ihr Name ist Roxanne und das ist ihre Geschichte. Tür-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-Tür auf, Interior Wohnzimmer. Oh mein Gott, das war der schlimmste Tag meines ganzen Lebens. Oh, was ist denn jetzt schon wieder los? Hast du versucht, rückwärts einzuparken? Karl, mein schwuler, bester Freund Karl, nein, es ist wirklich nicht zum Lachen.
Wieso hast du wieder versucht, für deinen Chef zu kochen? Nein, ich wurde gekündigt. Was soll ich denn jetzt machen? Du weisst, dass ich die Rechnung meines Vaters bezahlen muss. Du weisst, dass ich die nächste Zeit dich hier beherbergen muss, weil du eine Wohnung verloren hast. Ich muss für uns beide kochen. Wie soll ich das alles machen, jetzt wo ich kein Geld mehr habe? Roxanne, danke dir, dass du mich hier aufgenommen hast. Du hast wirklich ein grosses Herz. Oh. Und ich glaube, ich habe eine Idee.
Weil in dem Crepladen, in dem ich arbeite, da gibt es noch neun Posten. Da könntest du mitarbeiten. Aber du kennst mich. Ich habe zwei linke Daumen. Und versprich mir, dass du nicht alle Creps aufisst. Hahaha. Mein Sohn, ich dachte, ich habe einen Fehler begangen, als ich dich gezeugt habe. In dem Moment, als deine Mutter und ich im Bett lagen und unsere Leiber sich schwitzend aneinander gepresst haben und ich der Ekstase nahe überlegte, ist das wirklich eine gute Idee, noch einen menschlichen Leib in diese verkorkste Welt zu werfen, dachte ich, es wäre ein Fehler gewesen, dich zu zeugen. Und die letzten 37 Jahre habe ich das auch gedacht.
Doch heute, nach 37 Jahren, merke ich, es war kein Fehler. 37 Jahre habe ich das auch gedacht.
Doch heute, nach 37 Jahren, merke ich, es war kein Fehler, dich zu zeugen.
Papa, er ist tot.
Sagt wer?
Hallo?
Er ist tot.
Mama.
Die Mutter.
Wir sehen erst Stimme in Klammern O, S und dann Mutter. Out of the scene. Out of the scene. Scene work. Out of the scene work. Es tut. Es tut. Ja, das ist eine Serie in der Serie oder Film im Film oder Serie im Film. Ja, Gonzago. Wie ein Hamlet, das Stück im Stück, das aufgeführt wird.
Deswegen nennt man sowas im Allgemeinen auch Gonzago.
Gonzago, das Stück der Mörder von Gonzago, glaube ich.
Da weißt du was. Geht ja im Endeffekt alles wieder auf Shakespeare zurück.
Du willst es ja nicht wahrhaben, du rennst ja weg vor dem Baden.
Aber ich glaube, er wird dich eines Tages einholen
und dann fühlst du die kalten, kalten Hände an deiner Kehle.
Das werde ich
in meiner Fellow-Thespian-Gruppe
ansprechen.
Sie sind Funfact.
Das ist eigentlich ein Gonzago und dann wird der
Anführer der Gruppe mir die Hand ausstrecken.
Was hast du mit den anderen E-Bus gemacht?
Hast du die dabei noch oder wenn dir nur eine rausgefallen ist?
Ähm,
viele habe ich dabei.
Okay. Ist das für dich so ein Move, dass wenn du mit jemandem sprichst und dann so, du gibst mir Kopfschmerzen, oh Gott, ich muss kurz eine Ibu nehmen. So, als Move, um das zu machen? Ja, also seitdem ich die Tausend habe, definitiv. Ich bin noch viel freigebiger, ich gebe gerne Leuten Ibus, ich dränge Leuten Ibus auf, weil es halt auch viel Platz wegnimmt bei mir oben. Ich find's gut, ich schau grad wieder Love on the Spectrum, wo autistische Menschen und auch Menschen mit Down-Syndrom daten, die alle nicht viel Dating-Erfahrung haben und die haben auch Dating-Experten dabei, die sie unterstützen und sie beraten. Man denkt jetzt, Trash-TV-Vorführung wäre entwehnt. Nee, ist es, finde ich nicht. Ich finde, das ist alles sehr respektvoll. Da wird, glaube ich, ein paar Preise gewonnen für Inklusion und so weiter. Es macht so ultra Spaß. Ist wirklich super, man lernt wahnsinnig viel auch über Autismus und da gab es einen Autisten, der war dann bei so einem Speed-Dating, wo du immer so eine Minute hast und dann setzt man sich um und du hast so ein Blatt vor dir, wo du dann ankreuzen kannst, will ich weitertreffen, yes, oder will ich nicht weitertreffen? Und der hat immer schon Swipen eigentlich. Genau, im Grunde, ja. Und der hat immer schon während die Frau noch da saß, immer schon angekreuzt. Das heißt, er hat irgendwie gefragt, do you like lizards, do you like dinosaurs? Und dann sagt sie no und er ... und kreuzt no an direkt vor ihr. Aber ich bin ehrlich, man kann direkt weitermachen. Sie kann das nutzen jetzt als Pause, weil Speed-Dating, ich kenne das aus eigener Erfahrung, ist eine anstrengende Stunde oder zwei, aber, oder, we don't know, bis man halt jemanden findet. Teilweise wochenlang bist du da drin und dann hat sie jetzt kurz eine Pause, kann es einfach skippen direkt, wenn er direkt groß no anstrengt. Was mir auch gefällt, ist, dass dann diese Dating--Expertin beziehungsweise einfach, glaube ich, Autismus-Expertin, denen dann auch sagt, fragt nach Interessen, weil oft fällt ja dann sowas wie Smalltalk schwer oder so oder generell, weil die vielleicht Informationen des Gesicht nicht so gut ablesen können und das führt dann zu manchmal so Überkompensation, wie dass, wenn man etwas gut findet, der eine Charakter zumindest dazu neigt, dann ganz doll zu grinsen.
Und dann gab es auch so eine Frage, magst du, was magst du so gerne? Und dann kam Animes und er hat auch vorher gesagt, er mag Animes und dann wurde sein Gesicht ganz, ganz gross und das war so sehr, sehr rührend. Und dann sagt die andere Person, genau, und dann hat die Dating-Experte auch gesagt, wenn ihr gleiche Interessen findet, same
interests, dann redet darüber.
Ja. Und weil
die Frage ist auch, wovor redet man denn eigentlich?
Und ich finde da, ich habe da auch
sehr viel raus selber gezogen, weil ich dachte, ja, worüber
redet man eigentlich mit fremden Menschen?
Richtig, ja. Weil ich rede gerne über Details,
wie mit dir hier, stundenlang
über kleine, scheinbar unwichtige Details,
aber mit fremden Menschen
weiß ich auch manchmal einfach nicht.
Und dann, gut, findet sie
gleich Interessen, redet dann darüber.
Und dann war so, ah, what do you like for anime-animes?
Genau, und er hat auch erst mal betont,
ah, same interests, also gut,
eingeloggt, für sich selber, du weißt genau,
wo er im Gedanken ist, bam, eingeloggt,
ah, und dann sozusagen neuer Folder
geöffnet, wir reden jetzt darüber. Genau, ja. Dann hat er gesagt, oh, super Frage, was magst du denn für Animes? Sehr gut. Dann hat die zwei aufgezählt. Ja. Und das Thema war beendet. Das fand ich so stark, es war einfach so. So gut. Ja, ausdiskutiert. Er wollte das wissen, er hat gesagt, bam, that's it. Es ist so gut, aber es lehrt einem auch einiges so über Ehrlichkeit, ne? Ja. Also, dass du du nur sagst, ankreuzen, nein, ist zu ehrlich.
Man würde das nicht machen.
Und es ist so interessant, zu zwischenmenschlichen Dingen.
Ist Höchstheit nicht nur Lügen.
Ja, in gewisser Weise überlegt man so,
okay, was verdeckt man eigentlich immer so und warum und so.
Für jemanden, der das gar nicht macht,
der gar kein Problem damit hat, extrem ehrlich zu sein,
ist das super interessant.
Schaut gerne mal rein, Love on the Spectrum ist sehr, sehr süss.
Und da wird auch die ein oder andere Träne verdrückt.
Voll.
Weil die sind urextrem liebe Menschen. Die haben nichts Böses in sich, keinen Funken, irgendwas. Die sind so niedlich. Die haben die coolsten, nischigsten Hobbys, das ist ganz, ganz toll und vor allem, was ich das Rührendste finde, sind die Eltern, weil das sind oft unglaublich tolle, herzliche, nette Menschen, auch unglaublich lustig, die super viele Witze machen, auch über die Krankheit und über ihre Kids, aber nie, und das zeigt mir auch wieder, es geht immer nur um Kontext, es geht nie wirklich um den Inhalt. Und dann gibt es ja diese alte, als wir auch immer gestritten haben oder besprochen haben, welche Witze kann man machen, welche nicht. Diskutiert haben, ja. Kreativ gestritten haben, welche Witze kann man machen, welche nicht. Als wir noch mal zusammen Witze gemacht haben damals. Und nicht nur ins Mikrofon gehusstet haben, wie die letzten Folgen. Und dann haben wir oft Ricky Gervais zitiert, dass es nicht um das Thema geht, sondern um das Ziel des Jokes. Und das stimmt natürlich, aber ich würde sagen, nee, das kann auch sogar noch lustig sein, es geht nur um Kontext. Und von manchen Leuten ist manche Sachen einfach nicht witzig, aber von den Eltern, von den Leuten on the spectrum, wo das ja immer aus einem lovable place kommt, ist das einfach immer lustig. Man guckt das und ist so schön. Ich finde, das zeigt immer auch viel über Humor. Weil die sind auch alle ultra lustig. Ich bin ein Riesenfan von Michael. Michael ist einer der lustigsten Menschen. Der haut nur Banger raus. Und das ist wirklich schön anzugucken. Und die Eltern checken das und machen es auch. Und es ist sehr, sehr, ja, fehlt das deutsche Wort, wholesome. Ja, da brauchen wir ein Wort, schreibt es gerne ein, reicht es ein. Was ist dein Vorschlag? Weiterhin herzlich wohlfühlsam, wohlfühlig, warm und kuschelig.
Danke, dass ihr dabei wart, liebe Leute.
Es tut mir leid, ich war krank.
Ihr habt es vielleicht gemerkt hier und da,
falls es ein bisschen rüberkam.
Aber ich gelobe Besserung, wünscht mir alles Gute,
wünscht mir gute Besserung.
Haut rein. Wir beten für dich.
Macht's gut, betet für mich, aber auch für den Papst. 70, 30, muss schon im Prinzip sein.
Haut rein, jetzt heben wir ab.
Macht gute Besserung, Florentin.
Tschaui!
It's a worse bird production. Am besten mit einem neuen Auto, denn bei der bundesweiten Keno-Zusatzauslosung gibt es bis 18. Mai täglich Extra-Gewinne, einen Audi Q2 und 530 mal 100 Euro in bar.
Keno, die tägliche Zahlenlotterie, in jeder Lotto-Annahmestelle und auf Lotto-Bayern.de.
Lotto Bayern, nimm dein Glück in die Hand.